fue en el último vídeo que vimos algunos
tipos de isótopos de átomos que tienen
decaimiento radioactivo y que se
convierten en otro tipo de átomos o
liberan diferentes tipos de partículas
pero ahora la pregunta sería en qué
momento el átomo o el núcleo del átomo
decide decaer así que vamos a empezar
imaginando que a todos estos de aquí son
átomos tengo un montón de átomos que voy
a dibujar todos estos por aquí ok vamos
a dibujar un poco de átomos y entonces
imagínate que todos estos átomos de aquí
sufren algún cierto de decaimiento algún
tipo de radiación pero quiero esta vez
pensar en algún tipo de radiación en
donde un átomo se convierte en otro
átomo por lo tanto el número de sus
protones va a cambiar es decir tu número
atómico va a cambiar así que por lo
tanto puede ser o decaimiento tipo beta
radiación tipo beta que como vimos en el
vídeo pasado obtenemos protones de los
neutrones
o acaso la emisión de positrón en donde
obtenemos neutrones de los protones pero
bueno eso no es tan relevante aquí
imagínate que tenemos esta colección de
átomos porque realmente cuando tenemos
aunque sea una pequeña porción de
cualquier elemento tenemos un montón de
átomos de este elemento ya hemos hablado
de moles en algunos de nuestros vídeos
dijimos que 12 gramos de carbono 12 y es
más déjame ponerlo aquí 12 gramos 12
gramos de carbono 12 que por cierto su
número atómico es 6 ok esto es
equivalente a un mol esto es lo mismo
que un molde de carbono 12 y cuánto es
un molde de carbono 12 bueno pues esto
es lo mismo que 6.0 2 por 10 elevado a
la 23 átomos de carbono 12 en este caso
que por cierto este es un número enorme
es un número mucho
más grande de lo que mi cabeza puede
soportar y esto en 12 gramos 12 gramos
por cierto no es una masa muy grande por
ejemplo un kilogramo es cercano a 2
libras así que cuántos son 12 gramos
bueno como mucho es un 40 o cerca de un
50 agua de libra más o menos pero lo
importante es que no es mucha masa
realmente no es mucha más a la que
tenemos aquí y bueno la masa en la
tierra o bueno en donde sea es
invariable en fin regresemos a la
pregunta que queremos resolver en este
vídeo si alguno de estos tipos decide
decaer en qué momento sucede esto y
bueno tal vez no sea carbono 12 tal vez
hablemos de carbono 14 o lo que sea pero
lo importante es preguntarnos cómo saber
cuándo vamos a decaer y la respuesta es
no sabemos en todos los átomos existe
una cierta probabilidad de de caer en un
momento dado para algún tipo de elemento
o para algún tipo de isótopo de algún
elemento es decir existe una cierta
probabilidad de que uno de ellos decaiga
no sé por ejemplo este átomo éste átomo
puede caer en algún cierto segundo y
después de ello nada pase por un periodo
largo de tiempo largo de tiempo y de
repente estos dos átomos estos dos
átomos se caigan y bueno es que ya te
irás dando cuenta que la química como
también pasa en otras ciencias como la
física o la mecánica cuántica muchas
cosas son probabilísticas y bueno tal
vez si entramos con detalle en la
configuración del núcleo tal vez nos
quedaría más claro todo en términos
probabilísticos pero realmente no
sabemos pero realmente no sabemos qué es
lo que pasa dentro del núcleo por lo que
sólo podemos atribuir estas
probabilidades a algo que está
reaccionando pero
puedes decir ok cuál es la probabilidad
de que una molécula cualquiera reaccione
en un cierto segundo esa es una forma de
pensarlo pero también lo podemos pensar
a un nivel macro es decir trabajar con
cantidades muy grandes de átomos
entonces lo que hacemos es buscar
términos que nos ayuden a entender mejor
en torno a esta idea y uno de los
términos que nos van a ayudar es la vida
media pero para esto déjame borrar todo
esto que tengo justo aquí vamos a quitar
esto y ahora vamos a poner la siguiente
pantalla es este de aquí de lujo y esta
pantalla lo que me dice es que vamos a
trabajar con la idea de lo que significa
la vida media si escribo una reacción de
decaimiento justo como la tengo aquí
donde dice que el carbono 14 decae en
nitrógeno 14 hagamos un pequeño repaso
de lo que está pasando aquí porque
estamos pasando de 6 protones y dejen
utilizar este color estamos pasando de 6
protones
7 protones y date cuenta que tu masa
sigue siendo la misma nuestra masa sigue
siendo la misma así que dime qué es lo
que está pasando aquí bueno pues uno de
nuestros neutrones paso hacia el protón
y esto pasa porque emite un electrón a
lo cual también se le conoce como la
partícula beta que es justo esta de aquí
está de aquí es una partícula beta o la
podemos escribir de la siguiente manera
la podemos escribir como un electrón el
cual tiene una carga de menos 1 y aquí
escribimos un pequeño cero y no porque
tenga una masa de 0 sino porque su masa
es muy pequeña relativo a lo que pesa el
protón justo esta es la anotación para
escribir el electrón y entonces estamos
hablando de un decaimiento tipo beta
pero bueno este es sólo un repaso porque
la manera en que realmente pensamos la
vida media y para eso déjame traer este
color por aquí
imagínate que tenemos por aquí un bloque
10 gramos de carbono 14 y es que los
científicos se dieron cuenta que si
empezaban con un bloque de 10 gramos lo
voy a poner así 10 gramos de carbono 14
ok si empezamos con un bloque de 10
gramos de carbono 14 y yo dejo pasar la
vida media del carbono 14 y por cierto
este 14 recuerda que es lo que me está
diciendo es que estamos hablando de un
isótopo de carbono un isótopo cuya masa
es de 14 también existe el isótopo de
carbono cuya masa es el 12 pero recuerda
que el número atómico para hablar del
carbono es 6 el carbono tiene 6 protones
carbono 12 con 6 protones o carbono 14
con 6 protones pero es lo único que van
a diferir es en el número de neutrones
cuando tenemos el mismo elemento pero
que difiere en el número de neutrones se
le conoce como isótopo así que la
versión del carbono 14 o dicho de otra
manera del isótopo del carbono si
empezamos con 10 gramos y decimos que
la media es de cinco mil setecientos
cuarenta años justo esta que tengo aquí
esta es su vida media ok déjame ponerlo
así esta es su vida media eso quiere
decir que en el año 1 tenemos 10 gramos
de carbono 14 pero después de 5.740 años
la mitad de esto va a pasar a ser
nitrógeno 14 y bueno seguramente tú me
vas a decir y utilizamos el mismo color
para el nitrógeno seguramente tú me vas
a decir esta va a ser la mitad aunque va
a sufrir todo el decaimiento tipo beta
después de la vida media y es que de
hecho he visto este tipo de dibujos en
las clases de física o en las clases de
química y mi pregunta siempre ha sido
cómo sabe esta mitad que es la mitad que
debe de transformarse en nitrógeno o
bueno lo podemos pensar en la siguiente
manera como sabe la otra mitad que se
tiene que quedar como carbono y la
respuesta es
pues que ellos no saben de hecho no se
debe de dibujar de esta manera se debe
dibujar y es más déjame dibujar lo justo
por aquí
se debe de dibujar más o menos de la
siguiente manera
aquí tenemos nuestra barra de 10 gramos
de carbono 14 y qué es lo que va a pasar
después de 5.740 años bueno lo que pasa
es que probabilísticamente algunos de
estos tipos han comenzado a decaer en
nitrógeno alguno de todos estos tipos
han comenzado a decaer en nitrógeno y
ojo esto de una manera aleatoria son
puntos aleatorios y una vez transcurrido
cinco mil setecientos cuarenta años
tú puedes determinar que existe un 50
por ciento de probabilidad de que cada
uno de estos átomos de carbono cambien a
átomos de nitrógeno así que después de
cinco mil setecientos cuarenta años es
decir la vida media del carbono puedes
asegurar que existe un 50 por ciento de
chance
de estos átomos de estos átomos decaiga
en nitrógeno así que si tú retrocedes
después de la vida media la mitad de
estos átomos son ahora nitrógeno ahora
después de la vida media y mejor
ignoremos esto de aquí a déjame mejor
quitar esto de aquí después de la vida
media que es lo que va a pasar
pongamos aquí nuestra barra original con
esta barra empezamos que por cierto es
una barra que tiene 10 gramos 10 gramos
de carbono 14 de carbono 14 ok
después de nuestra primera vida media
que es lo que pasa
bueno pasamos de aquí para acá ok esto
es después de que haya transcurrido una
vida media que en este caso son cinco
mil setecientos cuarenta años y recuerda
que esta vida media es distinta para
cada uno de los materiales radioactivos
que trabajemos y bueno como solamente
nos queda el 50 por ciento de átomos que
decaigan
al nitrógeno 14 y bueno ahora date
cuenta que esta barra ya tiene 5 gramos
5 gramos de carbono 14 ok
solamente nos quedan 5 gramos de carbono
14 es decir la mitad y el restante los
otros 5 gramos ahora son de nitrógeno 14
el si el restante los restantes 5 gramos
ya son de nitrógeno 14 después de pensar
en el decaimiento tipo beta ahora qué va
a pasar después de que transcurra otra
vida media que va a pasar si pensamos en
la segunda vida media bueno pues
nosotros dijimos que después de una vida
media que en el caso del carbono 14 es
unos 5.740 años existe un 50 por ciento
de probabilidad y en el caso de que
hablemos de un solo átomo éste tendría
una probabilidad del 50 por ciento de
decaer así que si vemos qué pasa después
de otra vida media am y para eso déjame
mejor a agarrar este de aquí lo voy a
atrapar y lo voy a copiar
a pegar ok y ahora esto lo voy a poner
para acá para pensar qué es lo que va a
pasar después de la siguiente vida media
así que déjenme bajar un poco la
pantalla ok para hablar de la segunda
vida media de aquí para acá vamos a
pasar a nuestra segunda vida media o
esperar déjame cambiar de color de aquí
para acá y qué va a pasar en nuestra
segunda vida media dos vidas medias
bueno pues otra vez cada uno de los
átomos del carbono-14 tiene una
probabilidad del 50 por ciento de decaer
y por lo tanto después de transcurrida
otra vida media cada uno de los átomos
de carbono 14 que quedaban en la barra
anterior tiene un 50% de chance de
convertirse debe caer en una toma de
nitrógeno y por lo tanto van a quedar
muchos pero muchos más átomos aquí que
ahora han decaído en nitrógeno 14 y
bueno por la ley de los grandes números
la mitad de estos átomos que quedaban
ahora se ha decaído en nitrógeno 14 así
que ahora tenemos más conversiones de
átomos mucho
y bueno entonces date cuenta que ahora
solamente tenemos la mitad de la masa
del carbono 14 es decir 5 gramos entre
dos es 2.5 gramos ok esto de carbono 14
ok
mientras que es restante todo lo que se
ha convertido de nitrógeno 14 es a 7.5
gramos ahora tenemos 7.5 gramos de
nitrógeno 14 ok de lujo
esto después de que transcurrió otra
vida media y bueno podemos seguir
haciendo esto para pensar en el futuro
pues por cada vida media es decir por
cada cinco mil setecientos cuarenta años
en el caso del carbono-14 va a tener la
mitad de cantidad con la que iniciamos
pero con esto siempre vamos a tener una
parte de cantidad de carbono aunque sea
muy pero muy pero muy pequeña aunque sea
en fin decimal bueno pero vayámonos un
poco más abajo imagínate qué es lo que
pasa con un solo átomo
imagínate que por aquí tengo un átomo de
carbono 14 en este es mi átomo de
carbono 14 y por lo tanto entonces
tenemos 6 protones 1 2 3 4 5 ó 6 y aquí
tengo 6 protones y tengo 8 neutrones
porque estamos hablando del carbono 14
tengo 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 neutrones de lujo
y entonces también voy a tener 6
electrones y vamos a ponerlos aquí 12
es 4 5 o 6 o lo que sea está bien y
ahora qué va a pasar con este átomo de
carbono 14 que tengo aquí que es lo que
va a pasar con este átomo después de mí
y se me ocurre pensar en un segundo que
es lo que va a pasar después de un
segundo
bueno pues realmente no sabemos existe
una probabilidad de que siga siendo
carbono 14 pero también existe una
probabilidad de que después de un
segundo hayamos tenido la suerte de que
decayera en nitrógeno 14 y bueno qué va
a pasar después de un billón de años un
billón de años
bueno pues realmente no sabemos tampoco
podemos decir con certeza que lo más
seguro es que haya decaído al nitrógeno
14 pero no sabemos existe todavía una
pequeña probabilidad de que no sea así
este podría ser un núcleo ultra estable
el cual vaya en contra de todas las
probabilidades y se mantenga como
carbono 14 así que después de una vida
media si nos fijamos solamente en un
átomo
después de cinco mil setecientos
cuarenta años tú no sabes si este átomo
decayó a nitrógeno con este mismo átomo
tenemos una probabilidad del 50 por
ciento de que haya decaído en nitrógeno
ahora si te fijas en una cantidad enorme
de átomos como los que tenemos justo
aquí es decir si nos aproximamos al
número de avogadro o algo muy pero muy
grande
bueno pues tú puedes usar números muy
grandes y decir en promedio si todos los
átomos tienen una probabilidad del 50
por ciento de decaer y existen
muchísimos de ellos entonces la mitad de
ellos habrán decaído nitrógeno no sé
bien qué mitad pero recuerda que la
mitad de ellos habrá decaído y bueno es
que esto nos da pie a decir lo siguiente
vamos a poner un ejemplo para resolver
así que para esto déjenme borrar esta
pantalla aquí tenemos esta pantalla y
voy a poner una nueva pantalla ok y
bueno esto nos da pie a poner el
siguiente ejemplo si nosotros tenemos 80
gramos ampliarán ponerlo así 80 gramos
de un cierto elemento radioactivo no sé
vamos a llamarle x 80 gramos de el
elemento x ok y éste tiene una vida
media de no se me ocurre dos años
entonces vamos a decir que tiene una
vida vida media media ok de dos años dos
años me lo estoy inventando y espero que
salga bien ejercicio bueno digamos que
tomamos una máquina del tiempo y miramos
a nuestra muestra en un cierto tiempo
hacia adelante y nos damos cuenta que
solamente nos quedan 10 gramos de
nuestra muestra solamente nos quedan 10
gramos de nuestra muestra de nuestra
muestra x ok ahora lo que quiero saber
es cuánto tiempo ha pasado nos quedan
nos quedan nos quedan 10 gramos
este elemento equis y bueno como nos
quedan 10 gramos aunque te parece si lo
ponemos de la siguiente manera empezamos
con 80 gramos de este elemento x 80
gramos en el tiempo t igual a 0 pero
después pasa antes que me ponerlo con
este color va a pasar aquí una vida
media es decir pasan dos años y después
de que transcurran dos años que es lo
que va a pasar bueno pues no nos quedan
80 gramos nos queda la mitad de 80
gramos la mitad es 40 gramos nos quedan
40 gramos en el tiempo de igual a 2 han
transcurrido dos años y bueno si después
nos fijamos en que transcurran otros dos
años es decir otra vida media dos años
entonces cuánto nos va a quedar bueno
pues si te das cuenta nos va a quedar la
mitad de esto la mitad de 40 gramos es
20 gramos nos van a quedar 20 gramos en
el tiempo te iguala am dos y dos son
cuatro años
y si después nos fijamos en otra vida
media okay nos va a quedar la mitad de
esto pero que ya ves para dónde vamos
después de otros dos años ok
solamente nos va a quedar la mitad de 20
gramos que por cierto esto es lo mismo
que 10 gramos que es justo lo que
queríamos 10 gramos en el tiempo te
iguala 24 ó 6 en el tiempo de igual a 6
es decir para que nosotros tengamos 10
gramos de este elemento x en la que
habíamos empezado con 80 gramos y tiene
una vida media de 2 años y después nos
metemos en una máquina del tiempo y
bueno supongamos que no calibra este
viento máquina del tiempo y no sabes con
exactitud cuánto tiempo ha transcurrido
entonces miras a tu muestra y observas
que solamente quedan 10 gramos de la
cantidad inicial que tenías de este
elemento entonces sabes que han pasado y
déjame ponerlo con este color han pasado
una vida media ok
dos vidas medias tres vidas medias o
dicho de otra manera esto lo podemos
pensar como a una vida media ok
elevado a la tercera potencia 123
elevado a la cantidad de vidas medias
que han transcurrido es decir que
realmente nos queda solamente un octavo
de la cantidad inicial con la que
nosotros empezamos un medio al cubo es
lo mismo que un octavo y un octavo de 80
gramos son 10 gramos porque habían
transcurrido tres vidas medias y bueno
todo esto es lo que describe la idea de
la vida media y en el siguiente vídeo
vamos a explorar la idea de qué es lo
que pasa si queremos saber cuántas
partículas o cuántos gramos tenemos
después de no sé diez días o dos años y
medio o lo que sea y es justo lo que
haremos en el siguiente vídeo